[Music]
hi
hey folks here we are
wfrq cincinnati now just kidding we
might be drunk we're here what do you
got there i got a peeve already at look
at this [ __ ] uh-oh it's it's overflowing
the lip balm overflowing yeah it looks
like a prolapsed anus over there coming
out of that this looks like the start of
a dog dick look at this ha ha the old
lipstick this is brutal the red rocket
good movie good movie yeah great great
app by the way this oh sammy the best if
you haven't heard the simon rexep one of
my fave yeah apps um
but nothing worse than when a dog dick
or a cat dick gets hard yeah that's a
set's a day ruiner yeah it's really it's
really gross it's gross the dog just
spread eagle that thing's pointing at
you and then you just start sucking it
yeah
so gross weird it tastes like puppy chow
i know
but hey
that's uh it's a whole different summer
what do we got here peters
oh reposado
another wrong with that nice summer
drink
i got i got a bone to pick with tequila
yeah so everybody was telling me you
know ten five years ago i'm like oh my
hangovers are bad they're like tequila
and seltzer with a lime no hangover get
the clear stuff goes down easy i'm
hungover every night
now
i've switched to vodka that's really
good though that's good stuff um yeah i
don't i'm not a big uh
tequila guy i thought you i thought you
were always a tequila guy i love tequila
and i still like the taste and it's my
favorite shooter but vodka to me
dylan roof
by the way not my favorite john wick
really for breaking it down way better
shooter got to go fictional yeah yeah
what about lee harvey harvey i mean he
had one shot he nailed it one shot
just like eminem yeah yeah mom's
spaghetti all over that back seat
sorry poor onassis she was holding his
brains damn
maybe the first hot first lady
i think i'm gonna say a hot load of
brains all over her
yeah that was the first book she was a
hot is she the hottest first lady where
do you rank her as hot first ladies well
nobody wants to admit it but melania is
the hottest yeah i think so i think i
think michelle is in the mix yeah you
don't think so i think people give her a
pair a couple extra points
i think she's hot i think melania is
probably one
where's jackie i put jackie over over uh
michelle
michelle's got the best arms oh my lord
that's wild she is hot look at that
that's a how about that milf on the
train on the way here with the arms oh
my god we [ __ ] we looked at each
other
we looked at each other quickly and then
didn't waste any time and looked back at
the milf yes yes oh my god she's very
greek jackie jackie is hot dude she's
hot her dad's a an oil tycoon yeah
franklin onassis or some [ __ ] that that
hair is not helping her she's got the
hillary well yeah it was hot in the 60s
that uh bob
not a big fan of the bob no no no most
attractive first ladies
oh geez come on we're going back to taft
laura bush
i did hear that nancy reagan was a real
hoover
i didn't hear that
to bring it back to president laura bush
he's got bush
what happened to barbara barbara bush
looked like a regular lady one day the
next day she turned into where's the
beef later yeah what the hell she ended
up looking like [ __ ] the coach from
rocky what the hell happened
overnight
too
yeah all right all right michelle's not
bad michelle's good looking great
cheekbones michelle is an attractive
woman she is an attractive lady
her hands are bigger than mine but she's
an attractive lady yeah
it's not scoring any points in these
hand jobs no no good but uh i have like
melania is
[Music]
yeah i feel like they all have like
things that like turn me off about them
like first off michelle's got too much
to do i feel like she'd always be out
doing [ __ ]
like side projects whereas melania would
be doing side projects where i'm like
we're selling jewelry in the hamptons
again i know come on oh i know they
always have to have a cookbook oh wow
melania's hot that's her
there's a porn star who looks just like
her who might have the best porn body
out there i can't think of her name
there is something about uh i mean how
often do you think she and trump
actually [ __ ] when's the last time you
think they actually found not that often
but jeez look at the cans on uh ivana
is it ivana
it's ivanka ivanka havana fell down a
staircase
whoa
trump's wife is that right yeah oh she
died that was an abortion joke no she
died she died you didn't know that
no no she fell down a staircase and died
totally which is look let's be honest
like tragic but also you lived in a
pretty nice place in manhattan if you
had a staircase
the only way that's more first world if
like a butler push pushed her in the
right right uh pomeranian fed in her
remains
once a dog has human flesh it can't go
back you got to put it down really in
fact yeah damn ever tell you the old
story what story my dad was just became
friends with his old guy in the
neighborhood and
he would go over there and like kind of
feed him lunch every day because his
wife died so my dad would like go hang
out with him to be nice
so one day knocks on the door the old
guy doesn't answer and he's like oh
maybe he needs some alone time maybe
he's in the shower knocks on the door
the next day nothing next day a week
goes by and he goes you know what i'm
going in there
who knows what happened to this old guy
and he's pushing the door in he has keys
door won't open like unlocked but won't
open there's something blocking the door
push the door open
corpse blocking the door damn dogs had
eaten it
wow what kind of dog
what what kind of dogs two dobermans
damn yeah so uh they had to put them
down [ __ ] oh yeah i made the whole thing
up but a hell of a story
at least they got their last meal yeah
very important
yeah yeah what are you thinking last
meal prison
it's a tough one you know i i don't even
want this but for some reason lobster
mac and cheese just popped into my head
because it's covering a lot of food
groups good point good you're getting
like some some seafood but also some
cheese in there i mean it's
my gut says steak probably yeah what are
you steak frites probably hey that's not
bad yeah that's not bad well
part of me is like i want to go
something give me a slow cooker you know
maybe a brisket just because it'll buy
me a few more hours you know i think
they're getting it
pre-prepared i don't think you get the
extra 10. all right good point good
point how about uh
i go back to new orleans you know i get
boyle crawfish seafood gumbo crawfish a
toufey shrimp creole something like that
just to go back to the roots yeah you
gotta you go to local hero yes here here
like sure he murdered 12 but
he had gumbo right right i'd get some
like you know old black lady in new
orleans whose restaurant is struggling
i'd be like you cook it maybe get a
little publicity hopefully she knows
voodoo she puts a little pin in the
guard's neck he's like oh [ __ ] you got
me mark breaks free exactly i like uh
yeah steak is tough not to go with i do
love a good seafood i you know oh apple
pie for james dean that's what he said
would be these are they were asked what
their death row meals whoa
good one grilled cheese for sinatra what
is such a disappointing answer
interesting although you know what i
will say grilled cheese is is comforting
it's comfort food never not good it's
never not you can't [ __ ] it up can't
[ __ ] it up it's a rainy day with a
tomato soup maybe a dip
that's a great combo too the tomato soup
and the i mean that's childhood what
else
uh classic american cuisine for abe
lincoln just that's it a little vague a
little vague you want to leave that up
to interpretation they could come in
there with a ham sandwich french onion
soup for julia child but she she knew
she knew her [ __ ] yeah
breakfast of champions what is that
wheaties
for napoleon
not what they would choose that's like
dessert for elvis damn i know he was a
fan of the uh peanut butter and banana
sandwiches yeah they do the elvis burger
some places which i've never really had
the balls to no
to order figs for cleopatra they were
probably exotic in egypt braised pork
knuckle that sounds like a sex move
uh bourdain was yeah what did it say uh
a braised pork knuckle with uh
horseradish surveillance sausage and
sauerkraut well that does sound
delicious don't you want to be
international like these guys are like
oh i was in prague and i got a phone
call that my wife fell down the stairs
and died so i got to go fly out to meet
her like i wish i was like a jet seti
i'm not you know you gotta be rich but
like what do you love to be like ah
sinatra's like i'm in london but i'm
coming back
yeah come fly with me when he wrote that
that was like a that was like a pickup
line yes he's like i can get us on a
plane oh i would love to come fly with
me and they're like you have plane
access i know because we're all over the
country every weekend denver florida la
portland you name it but like to have
the world be your oyster like that yeah
got you know let's go to monaco yeah i
got to clear my head the world is your
oyster oysters aphrodisiac that's true
so is vagina
[Laughter]
here here
something about oysters it is i mean it
is kind of like eating a vagina it is
you're in there you're slurping right
right you stick your finger in yes some
smell worse than others
some are a little briny
[Laughter]
i like to put my vaginas on a cracker
too put a little ritz
you know what kind of like a oyster a
vagina it's always a toss-up is it going
to make me sick
yeah am i going to regret it later yeah
could this be a bad idea i mean we are
we are in albany
yes and uh
as i reach for my coaster slash fake tit
hey can't go wrong can we use this as a
coaster you think try it is it too risky
i think you do it
it's like a beanbag chair for a drink
there you go
ah maybe not that's a sign of a good tit
that should be how you test it yeah can
i hold a drink on it no that's a good
tip these tips rule man i know it's hard
and she reposted us this lady really
yeah whoever whoever she was
parker's wife lentil soup belushi
ah
this is from trey parker's wife yeah
isn't that right
are you serious
man if you're listening oh the dream
guest we want we want trey and matt on
this podcast we're south park hell yeah
super fans come on we'd love to have you
we've seen all the movies we've seen the
show it's it's probably one of the last
ballsy
societal commentary shows they're
grandfathered in from the 90s so it's
kind of like
they they they're just they kind of get
that pass which is awesome okay now
here's a quick because a lot of people
say well family guy southpaw they can do
this horribly offensive stuff because
it's a cartoon yeah it's animated
what if we animated ourselves as a
stand-up and just did crazy [ __ ] up
jokes
like 911 holocaust all this [ __ ] uh rape
race gay all these horrifying jokes but
we're animated i here's the problem no
one wants to watch stand up animated
yeah
here's where here's the closest you can
come and i think i get what you're
getting at think of like a ventriloquist
that but that's kind of what you're
saying the ventriloquist the dummy says
the bad [ __ ] that's right that's like
george he has like that although it
wasn't otto
i think that he was the bad guy with
that no i think the dummy was the dummy
was a dick
yeah well the ventriloquist dummy is the
one who
you know
that's like the closest because no one
wants to watch stand-up animated i don't
think
yeah i guess not that's a long hour it's
it's already
you're already losing something with it
being on like a screen and not in person
and then you're like taking another step
away i think yeah yeah that's true
you're not getting any facial expression
you're not getting any real body
movements no crowd you're probably right
but
i know what you're saying i mean and and
south park takes the level further where
it's like it's kids
you know what i mean yeah they're kids
so you're like it's adorable that
they're
dumb yeah and not just kids and animated
it's horribly animated it's very
primitive and they're you can't see
their mouths really it's it's genius
yeah the best what uh do you got any
peeves or wrecks
uh let me let me do this one as a peeve
uh
did a guy's podcast
i don't want to say uh he's a no-namer
but he's a young guy and he he asked me
to do it i said sure and i regretted it
and yada yada but uh i did it podcast of
the new one-night stand
yeah exactly i'm like i said too much
um
but uh i did it and i'm on his podcast
and he's going so uh
you know the format huh i'm like no i
don't know the format and he's like oh i
guess he doesn't listen
and i'm like yeah i don't i've never
heard of this i've never heard of you
why would i lose this really is starting
to sound like a hookup someone doesn't
listen
no i don't podcast one of those things
very similar both might ruin your life
at some point yeah it's true yeah it
comes back to haunt you yeah it lives
forever
so he was annoyed you hadn't done your
homework he's annoyed i didn't listen
i'm like dude i'm here like that's
enough yeah you're mad you're giving me
[ __ ] and he was like i'm god i'm half
joking here but i'm like i know i won't
listen to this either like i'll still
never listen
so like just you give me [ __ ] it's kind
of like with the comedian who goes uh
the host he's like what credit you want
you're like i don't know just say
netflix or whatever he's like
oh somebody's been on the tonight show
and you're like yeah i'm a comedian blow
me you asked u.s yeah i think the thing
with the thing is with the comedy
podcast is like do comics really listen
to comedy podcasts i guess like some do
well there's just so many there's so
many like i'm gonna pat let me pass up
marin and rogan and all these other
giant ones for this little guy over here
that i've never heard of yeah i just i
know i do know some people who will
listen to a little of an episode just to
get like all right i'm doing this let me
just see what the vibe is but i'm not
one of them no god no
i don't listen to many
comedy pockets i have too much comedy in
my life i'm at the club every night i
don't want more comedy give me sports
for the news give me an escape i hear
comedy i hear you yeah other other
things are good and
uh you know you listen to a comedy stuff
too much you can start mimicking and
[ __ ] seeps in you never know so i get it
but i do love a good good hour i re i'll
rewatch an old hour of people sometimes
stand up yeah
i might not watch the whole hour but i'm
like oh let me put on bigger and blacker
for like 10 minutes
classic man the big piece of chicken
robitussin that damn dude i don't have
six friends now that's three on three
without having your pancakes pancakes or
[ __ ] yeah
yeah no rock rock
top of his game just murdering so good
yeah like sometimes i'm like let me hear
the the first part of chewed up where he
does the n-word
uh [ __ ] chunk you know amazing it's
amazing it's like it's like a
masterpiece and i just want to see that
point and that's your opener yeah it's
your opener coming out the gate with
some [ __ ] heat i remember seeing that
and going to an open mic to and being
like you know a new comic around all
these other newcomers and we'd all seen
it we were like can you believe that
that was incredible it was it was a
great time it's also you have that
moment too where you're like what are
any of us doing i know i felt that way i
felt that way watching burr's new
special like man he's such a master at
towing that line in a in a in a perfect
way yeah he pisses everyone off a little
mm-hmm but you don't feel bad after
watching it he makes you feel good yeah
it's it's interesting to see an angry
comic that actually gives you life yeah
yeah i was fist pumping because here's
the problem with a lot of comics
they'll have a good uh good bit or
whatever but you're kind of going i
don't know about that i mean it's funny
i see what you did there there's a lot
of tricks with burr i'm like he's
absolutely right and that was hilarious
and it's hilarious because he's right he
hits all the holes he covers everything
he covers his bases everything he said
is correct it's gold the new special
rocks dude oh i loved it i loved it red
rocks baby
yeah outdoors yeah it still worked
because there's a couple outdoors ones
out there that aren't uh exactly magic
but this one is killer it's great mike
binder killed it burr killed it yeah
hour and a half i didn't get bored he
does that whole mushroom chunk about
like having an epiphany it was it was
[ __ ] awesome i i posted about it and
burr wrote thanks man it means a lot i'm
like
means a lot what are you kidding me a
lot you wrote back yeah he's the best
and uh
it's interesting man like hour and 20
something whatever yeah you don't get
bored to hold your attention
it's tough these days hell yeah oh yeah
which is tough we never say that [ __ ]
about movies
movies are getting longer i feel like
they are it's strange yeah all we do is
talk about like attention span attention
span and then movies are like three and
a half hour three hour fifteen i'm like
what are we doing here every show just
knows how to keep you watching too it's
like almost like that's like the the
medium now it's like every episode is
like
she's the killer actually and you're
like huh and then all right i'll watch
the beginning and then you're like oh no
she wasn't we we missed
we misspoke yeah all right but something
else happened right they just drag the
staircase we're gonna have 12-hour
episodes you're like we could knock this
out in 20 minutes it was like 15. was it
15 i don't know look at that that is
banana but it was so good i thought we
needed an episode for every step of the
staircase
it's ridiculous that it was incredible
though it was pretty great yeah i love
that lawyer
he's the man the owl theory come on the
owl theory and al i mean an owl killed
the woman that's what they're saying if
you haven't seen this show the staircase
the woman fell down a staircase and died
he had two wives who who died that way
one was ivanka
[Laughter]
um that would be crazy if they started
dating right before oh my god anything
again that would be hilarious um no
two wives was like you did it you killed
you killed them
that's too crazy no doubt coincidence
you're either the most unlucky person on
the planet no it's this is the show
you're pulling up see but they made a tv
show about it that's how big of an
impact that yeah but the one we're
talking about it's on netflix yeah yeah
it's like a docu-series
there it is
yeah but it's uh
they say it's an owl theory like a woman
she got hit by an owl and then fell down
the stairs it's like all right this
i mean this lawyer's got balls i'll give
you that oh i know the owl there's no
feather
there's no nothing we brought in a
surprise witness
oh it's you it just turns on who's on
first
hey that's not bad who's on first with
two owls 13 apps 13 amps but i will say
making a murderer dragged for for me
this was really good all the way through
i i i thought it dragged a little but i
i it was good i'll give it 94 some say
it dragged others say it fell
but no it was uh it was a great show it
was beautifully shot yeah it looked
great true crime that's my number two i
think ever
number one jinx number two stairs this
is two huh it's incredible it's
beautifully shot oh wow only 78 audience
were i thought it was
oh that's the show
yeah what do we got for the actual for
the other one
82 is good see i preferred night stalker
to this
but i think the story was more uh more
compelling it was a guy running around
killing people this is one guy and his
wife
two wives two wives night stalker that
guy was a [ __ ] creep
no maybe it's called something else
because it came out like 2021 or 2020.
yeah netflix no i know you're talking
about that hispanic guy in l.a yes yes
robert rodriguez
was it richard ramirez richard ramirez
yeah the other guy's a director yeah
yeah
he murdered a bunch of women but he did
make uh desperado which is pretty cool
yeah he put some hayek on the map
how about uh yeah i love the grizzle
detectives on these shows who are like
we were going to find this sick [ __ ] one
way or another yes and it became my
mission these sleepless detectives who
all they do like you just think about
their poor families at home
daddy we play catch he goes i'm looking
for the night stalker
but it was a different time it was back
like the wife would like you never see
your family anymore he's like shut up
[ __ ]
i got a badge to protect
he becomes a nightstalker she just keeps
nagging him shut up
it was a different time it was like 1970
san francisco what a what a great like
the zodiac killer it's such a great uh
moment in time
it really was a different time with all
these murders i mean like i mean i think
about the pre-dna [ __ ] like
it was like it's like home runs in the
steroid ever it's not even yes you're
just you're just putting up numbers and
i'm like
they're inflated that's a good point
they are inflated yeah these guys had no
roids they had no internet no uh
forensics
remember that mullany's a little bit
what was it he's like a john dillinger
back in the day he's like these cops
were trying to cheat they couldn't find
him he's like how did they do it there
was no dna so you'd be like uh like the
head detective sir there's a pool of
blood in the other room gross
now back to my hunch
i would think of the one how they used
to like shoot uh
oh the bullets yeah bullets free back
then yeah and you just say it was we did
it you know yeah yeah it's a challenger
gang whenever i see whenever i see like
uh peaky blinders like that's how they
rob you they're like it was the picky
blinders who did it and you're like
that's how easy it was to get away with
[ __ ] yeah you announced you announced
the gang you're in that's hilarious tell
everyone
so true
yeah milani milan good i got i got a
peeve i gotta please let me see what i
got i'll tell you what uh how about a
toast to tits yes new segments toast
here here
we do a lot of pees we should be
spreading some positivity new segment
idea a toast i love a toast i'll give a
toast
not just boobs i'll say this positive
energy you always have positive energy
oh you're easy to be around hey i'll
take it thank you i wish i could say the
same but enough
but
but no i try i try i heard i heard a
quote once uh you wouldn't bring your
bad breath around someone
why would you bring your bad attitude
and i blew my mind when i heard i was
like yeah that's true yeah because
people will come in if you go you got
bad breath they go jesus christ oh my
god they're so bad but if you go hey
you're being a dick like well [ __ ] you
you don't know what my life's about you
and you're like all right all right so
treat it like the bad breath be ashamed
of it that's a good point it's a great
ad for listerine too
your mouth stinks and so does your
[ __ ] personality
work on it done we should do commercials
we really should we could have a side
biz we could
um
oh yeah toes to tits i want to say this
as you age
the smaller the tit you're finer with
really well i think when you're you're
growing up you're like big tits big tits
oh my god you know baywatch all this
[ __ ] and like as i get older i'm like i
like a small tit a big tit a medium tint
a note well you're marrying a
well-endowed woman yeah you got a point
so you are i mean this is [ __ ] i
think maybe but i mean look i'm in porn
and i used to be like oh where are the
tits come on who's this a little boy get
out of here i want some that's my
computer
[Laughter]
and uh so yeah i'm like now i'm like
yeah look at these great little guys
you know i don't think the same goes for
for dicks who are you typing your
browser little guy
hey little buddy give me a kid with a
catcher's mitt goddammit
and a big lollipop um
celebs who have way what was the
headline celebs man you're crushing it
by the way a toast to peter yeah
crushing it on the [ __ ] computer at
all times in the gotham studios 11
celebs who prove having small boobs is
seriously hot all right let's see we'll
tell you if you're right
yeah
paris hilton i mean yeah you got to give
it to her i think she's underrated as a
sexy lady
underrated i think i don't think she you
know number one ever is like paris
hilton sexy i met her she is she just
oozes sexy yeah dude oozes
uh all right well this is weird cause
they're just they're just hot women
they're just hot women with uh clothing
oh yeah natalie porter what a mixed bag
to be on uh to be on the list like this
yeah you imagine like celebrities who
prove having a small dick is actually
kind of cool
well there's a whole tick tock trend now
oh rihanna's so hot rihanna's so hot
there's a whole tick tock trend of uh
women who like small dicks really i'm
like where was this when i was a kid not
only you kids banging teachers but
you're also rocking a small dog and
getting praise for it i was getting
laughed at it with tiny dicks
shamelessly sliding in
yeah yeah i mean who gives a [ __ ] all
right all right this is these are like
tens yeah these are hot women no one um
what do i have for a pee also i need to
see the tit these are just women in
clothing but that's another show here's
a peeve you ever have that friend who's
like they have too much pride to
apologize for the shitty thing they did
so now they just over apologize for
other meaningless things oh
well they do something really shitty to
you and then they're just like oh my god
i'm three minutes late i'm so sorry
what are you doing it's like oj he
murdered his wife but we got him on the
clothing scam you know we got him on the
merch memorabilia yeah the memorabilia
it's a memorabilia apology
yes exactly you cut your wife's head off
but we didn't get it same with al capone
al capone the murderer gangster but we
got him on tax evasion and syphilis and
syphilis they didn't end up killing him
yeah
that's it is something that bugs me when
the the friend like they've done
something shitty and then now he does it
all the time right he's like oh i really
messed up on this thing i was like no
that's not the thing that's not the
thing yeah i mean i think girlfriends do
that you know they're like you left the
dishes out again you're like jesus all
right what are you freaking out but you
actually you know
[ __ ] your sister or something that's
what's really going on
that's an extreme either way you wish
you could just scrub this whole thing
clean
yeah
here here her sister's name was dawn but
all right all right
um
yeah so that's a good one yeah that's
very relatable the the guy who does
horrible [ __ ] and then apologize for the
little thing yeah
apologize for the [ __ ] felony here
yeah
where are you at on the uh lending a guy
money
asking for the money and then he gets
mad at you i mean it's where am i at
it's it's insane behavior okay okay what
are you talking about who's who's siding
with that guy other than that guy
i feel like this is a common trait in
people i lent this guy a a hefty sum and
then years went by and i go hey any uh
luck with the finances and he's like
jesus
you piece of [ __ ] what do you chase bank
i'm like well i mean why am i the bad
guy i gave you money and now i'm the bad
guy for bringing it up oh i mean i think
you gave him too long a leash by giving
him years yeah you might be expected the
money back i did i said i'd like you to
pay me back goes i'll pay you back i
swear to god i'll pay you back and now
he's like giving posting vacation photos
yeah i might kill his wife i'm in cabo
st lucas are you kidding me exactly and
then he'll be like oh hold on geez let's
see what i got he gives me like a 20.
i'm like i'm not trying to nickel and
dime you here i want the [ __ ] the
lump sum what a [ __ ] prick yeah he's
a prick
damn is it a comic no no no that's an
old friend from new orleans damn yeah
but you know then they start going like
oh well i saw that netflix half hour
that must have paid pretty good it's
like yeah it did i earned that you come
today
come stan jesus christ cumstein's a good
insult i like it i'm trying to bring it
back [ __ ] stain jizz rag anything like
negative jizz related is pretty fun yeah
come guzzler
although my dad he got me pretty good he
said i wish you were [ __ ] staying
wow
no i'm joking but uh
pretty pretty yeah pretty good for a dad
to say to his son what uh yeah man
that's a pee of any other peeves no that
was all i had i had those those two the
the payback i was gonna save the payback
for a later guest all right but i might
have uh might have won the load on that
one but i'll i'll have something else
happen within two hours
um yeah i'm sure i'll annoy you i got a
wreck for you give me a wreck are you
guys watching the show the bear i hear
it's amazing it's pretty great you're
always a little ahead of me on shows i
think i think it's because you're in a
relationship that's what it is yeah yeah
when yeah you guys were watching
the full catalogs yeah you guys had seen
everything but this is like
it's so well shot that i had to google
the guy who's doing it that's when you
know a show is good where you're like
this is incredible he also did eighth
grade he did the cinematography on dan
soder's hbo special wow and a couple
other great things
some people call him the bear
and they're actually on christopher
street
yeah
so uh really cool show the acting's
great it's it's almost like an uncut
gems where you're just like oh god it's
so tense so stressful i'm freaking out
and i worked in kitchens or not kid i
was i worked as a waiter so i was a
restaurant guy for like 10 years so it
like brings you all back and you're like
how has this never been made there's a
show about the the life of a waiter and
the kitchen staff and the dishwasher and
the management and all the the
infighting and it's got like the coming
home element too yeah
yeah so what's the uh
yeah
it is shocking that a show like this has
never really been made i mean the movie
waiting i guess oh yeah very different
vibe from what it looks like it's gritty
yeah and
i mean fx will do [ __ ] like this every
once in a while i feel like fx is a
little up its own ass sometimes but
they're like yeah when they post with
things like fx fearless i'm like shut
the [ __ ] up right it's like when a
comedian's like i'm edgy i'm like you
don't say that if you're edgy exactly
you just make the [ __ ] fearless oh you
bought all the simpsons what a risk
big gamble on this brilliant cartoon we
all love but yeah this is like uh look i
mean just that shot like you can see
they put time into it and it feels like
it feels like real art again you're
watching art on tv which is so rare now
they've made they have made a lot of
good [ __ ] fx i mean the first couple
seasons of fargo were great louie was
obviously a great show yes uh i'm
missing i'm justified i will i heard
wilfred was good with elijah would never
really give a shot i never did either
but i heard it was good it was always on
after louie and i was like i'm good yeah
yeah it's kind of like when you're
watching snl the kid in the apollo comes
on you're like it's 1am
yeah when i was getting watched cartoons
and then donahue would come on you're
like i'm good
uh but yeah really cool show it looks
great and the premise is so good it's
this
kid
in chicago inner city his uh brother
owns a restaurant brother's an attic
shoots himself in the head
he became a culinary genius moved to new
york to work in you know these fine
dining french places yeah and then the
brother dies so he has to go operate the
restaurant back in chicago so it's a
huge step down it's all these ragtag
misfit cooks you know they're all
it's like basically a diner and he's
trying to make the diner kind of snazzy
and they're all fighting against it it's
it's pretty great oh abby elliott's in
it yeah it's uh i'm looking forward to
seeing the show i hear it's great uh
you're
i want to see the fourth or fifth person
to tell me and i've seen articles about
it
and uh
i'm gonna watch i also heard the old man
on fx is really good with jeff bridges
and john lithgow no i've never heard of
this yeah that's supposed to be pretty
good oh man huh but uh i mean hey man
they're fearless they swear
yeah that that's exactly what networks
don't want an old white
[Laughter]
them
man
the old man that is pretty fearless yeah
i heard the original site was the old
straight white man
they really went for it yeah but jeff
bridges you can't go wrong oh john
lithgow too man oh yeah heavyweights but
uh
yeah man it's supposed to be is that
good rotten tomato scores like audience
and critics let's see what they got
oh 84 90 i mean this is gold yeah yeah i
mean it looks solid
um i'm always looking for a new show to
watch i'm gonna i'm gonna watch the bear
first probably but uh it just tv drama
is inherently flawed because they have
to make up these they have to keep
getting more ridiculous with the
scenarios and the conflicts that it the
show tends to suffer
so it's hard to make them good for a
long time right but absolutely these
writers today are pretty great but uh
yeah i know i heard it's uh
i heard the bear is awesome man it's fun
it's fun you feel like whoa i'm watching
something it's cable you're like i can't
believe i'm watching something this good
on cable sometimes i'm watching
something before i go to bed though in
those like panic attacky type shows yes
that is the problem that's hard to be
like
it's not a wine downer for sure
i got a good wreck for you
a weighted blanket
oh i don't love them i love them my lady
likes them i don't i don't know why
don't you like them i don't want any
constriction in bed i want to be flappy
and free like like a loose vagina i want
to be all labia i want to kick my feet
out put my feet back in i want to throw
the pillow i want to be
uh
what's the word frictionless
i i like a weighted blanket it it it
keeps you down you know
it sounds bad like a straight white
exactly no uh
no they uh i like it it it helps me
sleep it's uh okay
you're not alone they're very popular my
lady likes them she's like it calms me
i'm like calm yeah improve sleep quality
i do feel like it helps the quality of
the sleep i know what you mean though
like someone breaks in the last thing
you want is like
yes yes exactly i hate that feeling i
feel like i've been uh one time i got
rolled up in a rug when i was a kid and
you want to kill yourself you're like
this is the worst day of my life you're
overdosed and your friends were like
toss them
like not yet
like all right i was like a crepe i was
in there i couldn't move a crepe yeah it
was brutal i love the french drug
addicts are good he's like a crepe
statutory crepe i was stuck
you're just so claustrophobic and you
can just kind of see a little light
above you because that's where the hole
is and oh my god it's like you're being
reborn yes not good smelled worse
but yeah and when i got out they slapped
me
it was brutal now word from our sponsor
better help you have to take care of
your mind folks we spend so much time
taking care of our skin our hair our
teeth and so little care of the most
important body part the brain
how well you take care of your brain
affects how you experience life
investing time and energy and mental
health is crucial to being happy eating
right working out and getting plenty of
sleep or a good start but no
substitution
for talk therapy better help makes
online therapy accessible convenient and
affordable we love therapy it's good for
you don't let those bags pile up
everybody's got [ __ ] in their life
everybody's got drama you gotta make it
work you got to be healthy and that's
how you do it is talking about it that's
how you get it out better help is online
therapy offers video phone and chat
therapy sessions you can choose to not
see anyone on camera and it's much more
affordable than in person you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours we might be drunk listeners get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
drunk that's b e t t e r h e l p
dot com slash drunk get on it we might
be drunk is sponsored by fanimal this is
the summer you're going to go out and do
[ __ ] if you want the best price for the
best shows this season use fanimel
fanimal has tickets to everything with
no fees the price you see is the price
you pay for hot tickets to a dodger game
or lady gaga fan mall is always the
cheapest option fanimals group purchase
makes it easy to get your friends
together set a size for you and your
group you choose a number of tickets you
want to pay for yourself then invite
friends when the group size is met
everyone gets charged and receives their
ticket if the minimum size isn't reached
in time nobody gets charged don't commit
until your friends do fandiml has
amazing customer service don't take our
word for it check out their hundreds of
five star reviews the next time you need
tickets go to fanimo.com and sign up
with code drunk for 20
of credit toward your first purchase
check out fanimal and experience
more animal
all right
support the show and get 20 off your
first purchase with the code drunk at uh
fandamel.com
if you haven't already it's smooth
oh if you haven't heard already it's
smooth sax summer the leading the leader
in below the belt grooming is making
sure we all have a ball this summer by
giving your pants
partners everything they need to stay
fresh
i love this thing you gotta love
the
manscape performance package 4.0 it's
got it all i use this thing on my sack i
go around the base of the shaft you just
want a little extra length and uh no
better equipment than these guys
manscape did it right they got a goddamn
headlight on the thing yeah and uh
you can't nick you can't cut i mean
there's a lot of veins down there and a
lot of uh
precious material you don't want to ruin
i just use it man it's it's i feel
lighter it's great yeah it works i had a
[ __ ] fro covering my balls
yeah
big fan our pubes look like our hair so
uh it's not that different and you need
a real i got sideburns too i need a real
mower down there the lawnmower 4.0 body
trimmer and weed whacker knows an ear
hair trimmer features
proprietary advanced skin safe
technology to perfect protect your
delicate parts and holes both are
waterproof so you can shave in the
shower come on get it all out in one go
manscape even threw in two free gifts to
their performance package 4.0 the
manscape boxers and shed
travel bag
take a look at the shears 2.0 a luxury
nail creaming kit grooming kit i keep
one in my
my bag all the time this kit includes
stainless steel nail cutters tweezers
and grooming scissors no more scratching
your lady in bed with those feet get 20
off
and free shipping with the code drunk at
manscaped.com that's 20 off plus free
shipping with the code drunk at
manscape.com it's smooth sack summer
boys get on board or get left behind
with your hairy ball bag
what uh i got another wreck for you all
right movie colin quinn wrecked it to me
it's awesome and i apologize if i'm
doing i'm doing i don't think i've done
this yet have i
well you tell me because i definitely uh
repeated a peeve yeah same i did uh we
drink on here like what do you guys do
what do you guys expect sometimes i'm
gonna say the same [ __ ] again and again
and that's how you know it's genuine if
you said it twice that means you really
do hate it all right here's my wreck a
weighted blanket
no i it's uh the movie mona lisa colin
quinn told me to watch it he's a big
film buff uh
i wanna lisa smile no mona lisa i've
never heard of it yeah bob hoskins
michael caine oh 86. yeah it's really
good um
they some call it the british taxi
driver whoa kind of a slow pace guy gets
out of prison drives around a prostitute
oh neil jordan did like the crying game
and a bunch of [ __ ] okay yeah it's good
it's a good flick is it is it a thriller
yeah it's kind of like a slow paced uh
weird story about a guy driving around a
hooker and you kind of slowly learn more
and more about both of them all right
and and they're dynamic and it's uh
british it's a good flick all right i'm
down it also just shows you what a
different place uh you know british
movies were than america's if you made a
movie about like a black prostitute and
a white guy driving around
in america that'd be like the whole
movie yeah
they'd be like we got this is the whole
thing it's the racial tension but in
england you're like yeah they're just
that's just who they are right
you know that's why i'll check that out
it looks right on my it's almost got a
noir vibe it's very noir okay this is
what uh patrice o'neill said in an
interview he's like i went to england
because in in america i'm a fat n-word
and in england i'm just a fat guy
so he's like i don't want to be seen as
black i just want to be a comic people
are going up to me you're fat he's like
thank you yeah
yeah
then he comes back to america jfk like
hey you fat you know
[Laughter]
but he said he got good like uh elephant
in the room was from going to london wow
he did london for three years not to
mention he was kicked out of about 11
comedy clubs banned wow so he had to had
to move on
he kind of got like cancelled
before the internet why don't we have a
patrice thing we gotta get it peters
we've all these passed on comedians well
there's no patrice we'll get one it'd be
nice yeah he's we could just get his toe
i gotta say you know i don't know when
this is coming out but i mean jack
knight it's horrible oh yeah that's
crazy very funny guy funny girl
super far already had a huge career he
was writing on big mouth for five
seasons wow and there's clips of him
being so damn funny on it like this
character and he's 28. yeah he was doing
so well at 28. and he was just like a
guy like i'm not gonna sit here and
actually i knew him well but every
interaction was just like he was just he
just
had a funniness about him yeah it was
just in him certain people positive yeah
yeah
no i only met him a few times and uh
always nice
cool first time i met him i was hosting
a showcase in los angeles uh for like
jfl or something and
i'm hosting it it's a lot of young guys
a lot of them aren't that funny he was
funny and he was confident and he i mean
dude he must have been like 20.
yeah it was a baby wow he was funny and
like
immediately ball busting me and silly
and i was like oh i like this guy yeah
really nice guy funny guy yeah he was
good at some of the stand like a year
ago and he was great did a netflix 15
with a lot of people we know like tim
dillon and uh that's right and ian
carmel and kate willa a lot of comics we
know and uh damn
and it was suicide yeah oh my god you
never know what people are going through
and i'm look here here's a little lesson
is i'm sure there's a comic out there
who he had beef with who i was friction
and then look what could happen we're so
petty and we we forget that like this is
also flimsy everyone's got something
everyone's got something going on and
you never know and you know uh yeah you
don't know what people are dealing with
right you know and and
also people you're friends with who are
just silly at the club and then they go
home and you're like you don't know what
they're going home to so i think there's
so many comics i know that are like
these like beaming forces of just
non-stop funny yeah and then they
probably are exhausted right when they
go out so you don't know and a lot of
people think like he got this he got
he's writer on netflix he's got it made
but you never know what's going on in
the in the head of course yeah if you
think money fans credits
you know if you think that's gonna turn
[ __ ] around for you like there is
emptiness at the end of that [ __ ] yeah i
mean you gotta find uh and if
and you can look at me and mark's tour
schedule we're still chasing it
nonetheless but no it's not a dragon
baby but it's uh
it's a tragedy and he just did a new
show on peacock which i haven't seen yet
but i hear his gray called the beat down
with langston kerman and sam jay and i
love langston yeah yeah damn great guy
see he was working he was doing it and
still
still still you never know what's going
on in that head you never know so yeah
if this is too late when this comes out
uh you know i apologize but uh we'll
we'll do something sooner too but uh
r.i.p toast toast to jack there you go
there's your toast
all right
now this is that weird moment in the uh
comedy show where you have to seg back
in the middle let's do let's do news
let's go oh good call hey good save and
squeeze the titties and get it light
again yes yes
woman oh you're sorry woman buys sex
doll for a husband that looks just like
her as an alternative to having a
threesome as well as take the pressure
off when she's not in the mood the uk
couple who earn a living on only fans
and can earn up to
122 000 a month were considering
exploring group sex but char had
reservations and was worried she might
get jealous damn now here's why i get a
little [ __ ] up with this cause
it's an interesting compromise the guy
wants to have a threesome she doesn't so
let's build a sex robot that looks just
like you first of all why would you do
that if you want to have a threesome now
you're just [ __ ] the the same lady
twice and secondly does she really look
like her she's got the same dress and
blonde hair
that's it doesn't look like her and also
like what how little do you move around
that emotionless doll is your
replacement
how lifeless is your body during sex
yeah where you're like i'd rather [ __ ]
this uh two-dimensional
skin
sack whatever this thing is over you
it's not a prize it's like it sounds
like a punishment if you're just like
yeah i'm not in the mood go [ __ ] that
doll yeah
cool uh this relationship is really
healthy for both of us but then she's
like the guy's like i gotta tell you the
dog is better head
somehow the head is better
i mean i think it's great the idea that
if like they have a threesome and he
just is all over the doll she's just
like because that's always a woman's
biggest fear that you have
and you're more into the other person
they bring in right that'd be great if
she's just laying there he's just like
[ __ ] the doll like crazy she's like
this is i know that would that would
hurt
yeah i don't know the doll thing it to
me
what are we doing yeah it's a waste it's
just taking up bed space put an oculus
on your head and play a [ __ ] video
game if that's real i mean that's not
bad yeah i'd like to try that the
calculus yeah that's the new game ah
there we go yeah
but yeah that's silly these people are
dead inside
man pushes peanut peanut up colorado
mountain what huh
i wish this guy had a peanut allergy
53 year old colorado man didn't crack
under pressure as he pushed a peanut to
the top of the 14
115 foot summit this week however he
didn't use his hands to move the peanut
along
12.6 mile route to the top of the
mountain he decided to let his nose do
the pushing this makes no sense to me i
don't understand how this yeah what the
[ __ ] he pushed a peanut up a mountain
with his nose for 12 miles
that's insane that's it's funny because
it's like one of those accomplishments
you tell people and they're like
yeah yeah okay
it's not like a cool guinness book it's
like yeah cool you did it but no one's
going to be like wow that's a really
cool idea i know dude you're just like
oh you have that much time you're that
much of a loser good yeah you take this
to the the planner ceo and they're like
okay yeah
yeah you don't want to do you don't want
to do business with them no no it's
[ __ ] weird
we're trying to get peanut eaters who
aren't [ __ ] weird yes
i guess in a weird way he might be good
at cunnilingus
somehow maybe there's a title yeah yeah
ladies like all right well you can do it
if you can do that for 12 hours you can
do this for 20 minutes you know
so maybe there's that he's got he's got
a better neck than i do i'll tell you
that yeah the neck is impressive
uh but yeah what a dork rhode island
duncan donut says it accidentally
ordered free coffee to white residents
a company spokesperson said the offer
was copy pasted from a similar offer in
white plains new york but only the word
planes was deleted so uh yeah just white
free white coffee this is how hungry we
are to like gotcha somebody like you
just put white residents like yes but
white plains you know what i [ __ ] up
yeah i could have put planes instead of
white but it happened to be this way
come on yeah they i apparently got in
worse trouble uh on their electricity
bill they actually only copy and pasted
white power
got way worse yeah
and then they they also
accidentally deleted the word out and
they said ah it's a black
dolphins recognize each other by tasting
one another's urine
the old r kelly flipper new research
suggests that the ocean mammals have a
unique sense of taste that allows them
to sense friends and family members
through piss
and other excretions i'm really sick of
people
saying dolphins and humans are so
similar
yeah they're always like dolphins have
the most similar brain i'm glad i i eat
dolphin how about that
i'm glad i [ __ ] eat you're not
dolphin safe anymore never eating that
dolphin have you seen uh that
documentary the cove yes that's [ __ ]
up the dolphin slaughter in taiji holy
[ __ ] wait isn't that the one where they
did the the trainer jerks them off or is
that a different one it doesn't sound
like that movie at all oh never mind
[Laughter]
i saw a different dolphin movie no the
cove it's like uh dolphin slaughter and
they're like feeding to the kids it's
got crazy sodium levels they're
slaughtering these dolphins people are
really mad about it oh wow it's funny
you can get me on the side of any
environmentalist if they make a
documentary about it and then like two
weeks later i was like yeah i'd eat
dolphins yeah why not bring it on well
why do we eat tuna and not dolphin what
makes a dolphin better than a tuna i
think tuna is more nutritious right so
that's it probably okay because we act
like oh this guy's a monster he ate a
dolphin but if it just comes down to
nutrition then well don't lobsters have
similar nervous systems to humans yeah
we put them in a pot
and they literally see it's very high in
mercury and may pose a health danger to
humans when consumed that's probably it
that's it huh i don't know it feels like
there's some moral thing about eating
dolphins
but if it's just a nutrition because i
mean a twinkie is not nutritious either
it's known as a mahi mahi in the pacific
i really answered for another rather
delicious fish known as the dolphin fish
someone who can you eat giraffe let me
see that
i just want a yes sir that's the problem
with the internet they give you all
these [ __ ] up answers but whoever came
up with
that's higher that guy's higher than
giraffe [ __ ]
that guy needs a high five
i love lines like that we have no idea
who thought of it yeah you know there's
a million like even the first guy to go
is that clear
crystal
like somebody to think of that yeah and
we just don't know who did it a toast to
the people who thought of things yes
the unsung heroes the unsung heroes yes
so
giraffe [ __ ] i'm sure you can eat
anything at the end of the day like if
you ever watch that show alive these
people are out there in the middle of
hell and it's like alaska and they just
start eating squirrels and nuts and
berries squirrels they're eating like
one guy a bunch of um she was like a lot
of work
yeah
through all that hair and i know like a
bushy tail and stuff and yeah it's
probably pretty gamey yeah it's gamey
yeah
you know what's cute about squirrels
they hide acorns like they gather all
these acorns and they hide a bunch and
they forget where they all were and
that's how a tree grows
is that true how cute is that give it a
[ __ ] wow i did not know that that's
adorable it feels like a pixar plot have
they not made a good squirrel pixar
movie ah that's a good question girls
are kind of adorable they're adorable i
mean they're full of stds but
but that fluffy tail really saves them
and they're so quick if they had a
grosser tail we'd look at them like rats
but that little fluffy tail really yeah
and in the words of george cartwright
estimates the number of new accidental
squirrel trees planted each year range
in the millions globally come on wow but
in the words of george carlin where's
all the squirrel [ __ ] that's like a
great carlin observation i love this
joke about how mice don't have uh
shoulders
that's a dumb observation i love that oh
how about a patrice's bit about how he's
like we feel bad we eat animals we eat
fish all the time because they don't
have eyebrows they're not like
that's such a good point that's a great
point eyebrows really help that well we
know thanks
no one's eating me
ugh what about this oh yeah you're
pretty hairy yeah you'd be like ah [ __ ]
i got another one so it'd be a lot of
work to eat me a lot of work you'd have
to shave it yeah it's a lot of work now
have you heard about this this is pretty
wild comedian craig robinson evacuated
from north carolina comedy club due to
gunfire uh an unidentified man
brandished a firearm inside the comedy
zone in charlotte and discharged his
weapon i mean this is a club we both
play yeah you got that right great club
great club but it's such kind of a vague
i read the story and i was like
was he in the room did he shoot did
anyone get hit why did he brand a weapon
what was his motive there's no
information on this story yeah
something's missing and then craig
robinson said he went next door to the
arena and played there and i'm like
so you were
lucid enough to go play a show the same
night i mean wouldn't that [ __ ] you up a
little bit if somebody shot in your cl
in your show i don't know something's
off here
yeah i don't know that's he appears in
court
okay
i feel like uh we're missing a
a step or something very strange
but uh okay in lieu of events last night
we'd like to thank all the amazing
people that work day in and day out blah
blah blah
is going to take a short breather
okay
all right that's a hell of a closer
pulling a gun out
i guess craig robin's got new merch now
hey
get the gun shirt
andrew tate in hot water again after
telling women to stay home oh this guy
this guy's just like a provocateur i
don't know who he is
he's one of these internet guys who's
like women should be in the kitchen and
you know let the man do his job and the
woman is the subordinate you know he's
one of those types
yeah there's always one guy like what's
the clip i don't see can we not play it
he's trying
it could just be like women just go on
holiday to have fun and men will try and
sleep with you so
does that mean the women are correct
because this is what i'm saying oh great
no no i agree let me agree with you it's
not what really do you agree with we
agree no we don't move on to the next
question no we agree we agree you're
right they're gonna try and you're not
gonna let them i agree if i walk out to
the car park it doesn't matter how good
the locks are on my car if someone's
trying to break into my car am i gonna
let them keep trying no no it's
disrespectful it's mine and no one comes
near it because it's mine no one's gonna
try and steal it for me too i'll put it
in a place where people are gonna try
and steal it is nothing less than
irresponsible my females taken care of
and has a fantastic life she does not
need to go on holidays can make an
awesome be a hoe on some random table
it's a random table because a friend met
some dude on contender no stay home
stay home hmm
interesting i don't just don't always
getting so worked up i mean like he says
all that [ __ ] in a calm voice it's not
making headlines right yeah i mean it's
not cool but also like yeah comparing a
woman to your car uh right
it's like there's a lot like we're
basically just calling her an object
here yeah yeah
yeah that's true
uh it's tough i mean i don't know really
the context what he was saying but uh i
think he's just that guy there's always
one of these guys like remember the uh
the guy
what was that book that went viral that
everybody liked oh tucker max not
tuckerbacks the other guy like how to
how to like nega women oh the game the
game that guy and it's all [ __ ] it's
like they're like you got a peacock i'm
like
i've seen some losers in fedoras i don't
know if that [ __ ] works dude i think i
think this works for you
but also those dudes like i've seen
dudes try to follow that [ __ ] and i'm
like you just look like a tool i know
you're getting laid but like you've
sacrificed who you are yes yes they're
wearing sunglasses inside at a casino
they got flames on their shirt and
they're like oh they got a weird soul
patch you know and a chain wallet for
some reason and they're like hey [ __ ]
get me a drink and she's like what
you're like this is your thing now
you're gonna be this guy come on
what's up with that shirt oh this shirt
oh i didn't even realize i'm wearing it
it's because you're so hot that i'm on
fire now exactly
i know cool
uh and their whole life becomes about
like slaying puss
which look i get it we all like a good
clam but also if you got a thing going
like put all that time into playing the
piano or or writing a book or something
you know into a career or a hobby i just
think it's gross when people reduce
women to their body parts
there we go tits toast um yeah no i i
mark's right these types of dudes are
always uh
it's like a vibe it's like a thing he's
like this is who i am yeah um this is my
audience so yeah your girlfriend is a
night i don't get so it's like she can't
go on vacation is what he's saying
without him i don't i don't get it i
think so yeah because somebody's gonna
try to bang her
a la breaking the car i mean look we all
have trust issues but
i mean it's just like what do you why
why the passion like why like it's to me
i'm just like oh this guy's been hurt in
this way yeah something's going on
that's what i hear i don't i don't know
needs a hug
maybe mom wasn't around
you always hear about daddy she's about
mom issues those exist too oh yeah this
guy might have mom issues mom issues i
feel like we talk about them now it
feels like a magazine i would buy too
mom issues
hey
what's going on here
denise richards showcases her cleavage
in racy red lingerie as she continues to
promote her only fans last month denise
richards launched her own only fans page
after her daughter sammy sheen oh
[ __ ] wow so instead of telling her
daughter not to do that she's like i'm
in
yeah you can't beat uh
mom here you know she i created your ass
and i could also uh
out tit ya i i will say i mean
you never know where life's gonna take
you i had such a crush on denise
richards as a kid i mean i remember uh
i remember being like oh wait does it
tell you how many followers they have
and stuff
this is denise richards only fans paige
i've never seen this i've never been on
yeah i mean this is exciting yeah denise
richards uh
wild things i mean starship troopers i
remember all that [ __ ] of course of
course charlie sheen's
uh wife there charlie if you're
listening we want you on this podcast
yes everyone immediately start
commenting on sheen's instagram right
now come on we might be drunk tag at we
might be drunk so he knows what you're
talking about
everyone go to sheen now we've been
trying to get sheen for a long time oh
yeah we'll take emilio estevez also
whatever you can get us
but we want shane now who would you
rather would you go mom or daughter here
jeez it's they're both very attractive
both i'm gonna say
neither out of respect to us pursuing
charlie at some point
but is that charlie's kid yeah oh it is
sammy sheen oh jeez i didn't see that
okay that makes sense no it's martin's
kid
[Laughter]
what uh
why what are you saying mark i might i
gotta go mom just because uh i mean look
if you've been with sheen you're going
to be an animal i mean there's no way
she doesn't do anal and they're both
beautiful
both very attractive both gorgeous i
don't love the the the younger one has a
bit of a
oh i'm innocent is this okay i like the
mom she's like let's go put your balls
on my forehead seasoned seasoned yes i
like balls they're they're salty
sorry i like i like a vet oh yeah yeah
give me a bed i support the troops yeah
here here all right sammy
that [ __ ] only i know a couple ladies on
only fans who i'm friends with and i'm
like part of me i could just go online
and
and now i can see a nip yeah
yeah yeah i don't know i mean
this is
people are making crazy money on this
[ __ ] it's a very interesting time hey
don't objectify women hey we're all
equal hey i'm not an object but check
out my only fans where i show every body
part for money it's a very strange uh
well i will say there's something very
you know my body my choice about it
we're talking about we're talking how
could you be pro choice and against this
right i mean
i will say that like you know well no
one no one's getting hurt i guess is the
argument because no one's getting paid
off their abortion yeah
i made a hundred and twenty thousand
dollars last month on uh abortion fans
i've actually paid for a few abortions
oh yeah but you're not getting it i
didn't get it yeah neither did you gee
she actually lost something but yeah
good point
all right well hey good news good news
brother denise
maybe i'll get on only fans
do you have to pay per
i've never done it i gotta pay per so
you really gotta fall in love with
somebody and didn't want to see it see
if it was a buffet that'd be different i
think here's what bothers me about it in
theory as a consumer
if you went to a strip club
you leave the only fans you never leave
you're like you're always there right
you can always just log on they have
your credit card yeah i mean it's it
seems crazy i don't know that's true
wow see this is this is female privilege
by the way yeah who are the top male
earners i want to see three dollars mia
khalifa i can watch her for free on porn
cardi b is on there whoa cardi b bella
thorne i've heard of her
wow people i wonder how their agents
respond they're like what are you doing
yeah like give me a cut please yes
please give me a cut because i'm i'm
subscribed
wow
who are the top men on there oh
interesting
bella thorne isn't she's very attractive
yeah
she was on bill maher's podcast oh
really oh yeah he was all over club
random yes
okay people all right
why would you have kids okay
the best uh dunnigan kyle dunn oh my god
my favorite
that guy is underrated
um
oh yeah well this is a new low we've
just sunk to uh
matt trying to hack in only fans are you
trying to see the men
yeah we're really [ __ ] up your
browser oh yeah i love matt's wife
coming in like what the [ __ ] he's like
it's not what you think
then she scrolls back a few she's like
you wanna have a threesome with a sex
robot that looks just like me
oh no
all right
well
i think we've got to wrap this thing up
here should we do a bed or something oh
we should do a bid yes for sure what do
you got
here we go baby pulling out the master
list and hopefully bodega cat is here
any day now i mean yeah we got a nice
text today we might have to just open
the episode with the push
what do you mean like we'll just add
something you know oh okay yeah yeah
uh uh oh [ __ ] i got that amazon
thing you saved me on that bit really
yeah your angle was the one that worked
oh yeah just about how amazon
i was like is it weird that adopted kids
don't have reviews
and then i was like amazon man you're
like it should be amazon should get into
the adoption game and that took it into
the to the right direction sweet but
hold on you got something i'm still
looking i had one i think could be
something there's something the other
day i saw a guy peeing in broad daylight
just on the street and this woman walks
up to him and she goes
what's wrong with you hmm it's like what
what do you you want like an answer
right
you think this dude is gonna like be
like oh i'm so sorry i didn't know like
to me i'm like who's crazier the crazy
person or the person who thinks she can
communicate with the crazy person
it's like you see that person the train
it's almost like a guy's just like ah
and she's like keep it down right right
keep it down yeah it's weird to ask a
question you can be like hey get out of
here sicko or hey you pervert i hate you
a piece of [ __ ] but to ask a question
like what are we doing are you trying to
get to the bottom of this yeah
yeah yeah do you want an answer it's
funny
and i like
the guy
you think he knows he's not supposed to
like he doesn't care regardless you
think he's going to pull his dick back
and he goes i had no idea yeah i'm sorry
years ago i was at broadway comedy club
and i i know i was looking and i was so
broke that i opened the cooler and i
stole a bottle out of it like a beer
bottle and i was drinking some guy was
like a worker was like what are you
doing you can't steal that i'm like yeah
i know
i was like i thought no one saw me also
every other club doesn't charge us for
this
you're the only club that's trying to
make money off comedians having one beer
i had to steal it yeah it was bad we
used to get lit up at caroline's for
free i remember that oh those were the
days baby old fashions
yeah
i think you got something there because
it's so relatable like
what is wrong with you my i don't live
around here and i gotta piss yeah it's
pretty easy it's like that james smith
joke just like well why do men cheat
oprah was like why do they they want to
[ __ ] other chicks
i love james smith oh yeah i miss that
guy simple answer nice and easy i think
it's cause we want to [ __ ] other chicks
out bro
all right i've been trying to crack the
code on this bit and it needs a it's
missing an element yeah hit me sometimes
a joke is just missing an element yeah
so i talk about how my dad just kind of
he's kind of out to lunch like he
doesn't give a [ __ ] or whatever you know
if you're like is he proud of you and
i'm like i don't know i want to do this
whole thing about how dads
don't really care that much like he's a
good dad he was a provider or whatever
but that's why there's no fathers
against drunk driving
you know we got moms getting drunk
driving shouldn't it be fad isn't it
weird that there's no fathers
like
how did that go down like the wife is
like we got to get together and help
these kids and the dad's like hey
that's a great organization honey but
i've had 12 beers and i got to get the
car home man maybe there's this all
right you drive
oh yeah that's not bad i think it's you
know yeah i hear what you're saying i
think i think it's a great premise this
is an old premise of yours i remember
you bringing this up to me once
so
there's not enough there i don't know
well it's funny like the idea that uh
i mean i feel like men just drink and
drive more right i just feel like that's
like i could be totally wrong on those
stats what do you think is that crazy i
think it's something about like
a guy will be like
i gotta be like i'm i'm thinking like
how kids were made i'm like i bet that
guy came over drunk or something right
oh that's interesting like guys just
think of their high points drinking and
driving yeah like i made it to this
chick's house and i [ __ ] her you know
yeah you don't think it's the lowest uh
oh is this new or is this a joke
oh no
hilarious wow that bit's over
[ __ ] me no i think you can save it by
saying you know there's a father against
strong driving but you never hear about
it you never hear about it and why
wouldn't they combine shouldn't it be
parents pad
isn't it weird i think i think maybe
that's the joke where you said rivaling
well you have a guy on that you're like
yeah yeah do you know there's a father's
against drunk drug i've been there like
why don't they combine they're like we
don't know but they're getting crushed
they're raising no money
they're spending it all on drinking yeah
yeah exactly cause
the moms we've all heard of mothers
against drunk driving no one's heard of
fad
wow
and why are there women in there oh
those might be the kids
it's just weird those are separated
shouldn't the parents come together on
this
and maybe the angle is like there's
nothing else like that you know like
there's no organization where a mom is
like we got to stop these kids from
doing heroin the dad's like i'm out
but we're with fathers against drunk
driving it's somehow they are out
mother's against date rape we're like
we're gonna do our own you're like you
don't want to combine like we'll see who
wins yeah
yeah yeah maybe that's the angle
okay why are we separating fundraising
you know why why are we reducing it like
some woman's like can i join the like
are you a father
yeah yeah
no it shouldn't be by sex
yeah i don't know there's something
there something there i'll play with it
i'm gonna i'm gonna
a good point where i got like all the
stuff i need to get working and then i
have no new ideas oh i have not my new
[ __ ] sucks hard to work on new stuff in
west palm beach i'll tell you
[Music]
not a great uh
i mean look they they were good crowds
but they like i feel like i'd be killing
for like 45 50 and then around the
50-minute mark they're just like
yeah i'm back oh you're done huh i know
and the they start late over there a lot
i don't think that helps that doesn't
help them the boo you can you can almost
tell when the booze kicks in in a whole
unit of people you know
like the feature has a good set you're
killing up top first 20s lights out and
then it's just like
that's how i felt when i was there and
i'll be there in two weeks
i had a great time but yeah that is
definitely the
this is hard to work on [ __ ] in florida
it really is they get rowdy yeah and
they don't like an unpolished bit you
got to come at them
yeah i feel like tampa is like the only
place you can kind of work on [ __ ] but
like miami orlando [ __ ] uh
jacksonville yeah you got to bring the
heat you got to bring it folks
they they want to party they're ready to
go salsa dancing and we're in the way
like uh anxiety sucks
i got fake tits and cocaine
they're like what what is that yeah i
feel great
the weather here is awesome and we do
drugs so
oh yeah
um should we plug dates hell yeah where
are you going to be there make sure to
get our merch at we might be
drunkpod.com sign up for the patreon
yeah we got some cool [ __ ] going on
tequila is good and uh we got
a lot of great guests coming up a lot of
awesome stuff
tell your friends about the pod i feel
like it's growing so quickly we got a
los angeles added another show we might
add another as well bourbon room uh
august 17th through 18th pittsburgh
improv the following week dania beach
florida louisville
irvine
omaha
phoenix
lexington kentucky new brunswick new
jersey oklahoma city springfield
missouri fort wayne indiana on
thanksgiving
wow
uh glad i agreed to that one talk about
dad's not being around
that's a tough one kansas city tacoma
spokane uh a lot of a lot of you know
we're not hitting all the i see people
getting mags they did san jose and no sf
i'm coming dude yeah i'm working on a
new act i don't want to hit every
[ __ ] city quite yet
you got that right i will be there it's
not it's not because i don't like your
city i [ __ ] love your city uh-huh
what about uh
[Music]
maybe a special
you got a ballpark on a date
september 1st whoa
okay netflix
wow
peter's jaw hit the floor
that was adorable all right all right
well geez way to sneak that in at the
end just like a pinky in the pooper it
came out of nowhere and like a pinky in
the pooper it was nice
[Laughter]
well
uh yeah that's exciting all right tune
in folks i mean that's right around the
corner that's august is gonna fly by and
here we are don't remind me bro
but you got a little time to to start uh
polishing up that uh pissing on the
street bit
so kill me
no you'll be fine
yeah the the crowd they they get it now
the audience is so comedy savvy they
know what's what
all right i'm at the comedy connection
we already added shows so get those
tickets we're at the west palm beach
improv we just trashed it portland maine
at the aura
uh back with bert in the fully loaded
brandon mississippi we had a makeup date
uh richmond funny bone red rocks
amphitheater with bert
some kind of brewing company and bake uh
terabor
terumbler
what's that say peters
temblor oh temblor okay bakersfield
california looks like yeah that'll be
interesting i've never been to
bakersfield san jose improv the danforth
music hall in toronto royal oak michigan
with i'm actually with jeff ausmus and
that one roction theater just got past
the cellar hey
killer comic great comics we follow
jeffrey asmus on uh it's pronounced
awesome spelled asmus yes on instagram
great clips funny guy revolution hall in
portland a pantage in minneapolis
neptune vogue joy
new orleans vancouver seattle portland
boston philly nashville come on by
we might be drunk say hello on the road
buy a shirt get on the patreon
check out our specials and congrats
september 1st
thank you
[Music]
and i get down in the same way
[Music]
this woman doesn't look like i remember
[Music]
you